let me ask the kind of political
sounding question which is how people
usually phrase it did Anthony fauci
uh fund gain of function research at the
Wuhan Institute of virology so it
depends I mean I've obviously been very
closely monitoring this I've spoken a
lot about it I've written about it
and it depends on I mean not to quote
Bill Clinton but to quote Bill Clinton
it depends on what the definition of is
is and so if you use a common sense
definition of gain of function and by
gain of function there are lots of
things like Gene therapies that are gain
of function but here what we mean is
gain a function for uh pathogens able
potentially able to create human
pandemics but if you use the kind of
Common Sense language and well then he
probably did if you use the technical
language from a 2017 NIH document and
you read that language very narrowly I
think you can make a credible argument
that he that he did not there's a
question though and and Francis Collins
talked about that in his in his
interview with you but then there's a
question that we know from now that we
have the information of the reports
submitted by equal Health Alliance to
the the NIH and some of which were late
or not even delivered that some of this
research was done on MERS Middle Eastern
respiratory syndrome virus and if that
was the case
um there is a I think a colorable
argument that that would be considered
gain of function research even by the
narrow language of that 2017 document
but I but I I definitely think and I've
said this repeatedly that Rand Paul can
be right and Tony fauci can be right and
the question is
um what how are we defining gain a
function and that's why I've always said
the question in my mind isn't was it or
wasn't it gain of function as if that's
like a binary thing if if not grade and
if yes guilty the question is just what
work was being done at the Wuhan
Institute of virology what role if any
did U.S government funding play in
supporting that that work and what
rights do we all have as as as human
beings and as American citizens and
taxpayers to get all of the relevant
information about them so let's try to
kind of
dissect this so who frustrates you more
Rand Paul
or Anthony falachian's discussion or the
discussion itself so for example gain a
function
is a term that's kind of more used
uh just to mean
making uh playing with viruses in the
lab to try to develop more dangerous
viruses
is this uh kind of research
um
a good idea
is it also a good idea for us to talk
about it in public in the political way
that has been talked about is it okay
that
um
us may have funded gain of functional
research elsewhere I mean it's kind of
assumed uh just like with Bill Clinton
there was very little discussion of uh I
think correct me if I'm wrong but you
know whether it's okay for a president
male or female to have extramarital sex
okay or is it okay for a president to
have
uh extramarital sex with people on their
on his staff
or her staff
it was more the discussion of lying I
think it was did you did you lie about
having sex or not and in this gain of
function discussion what frustrates me
personally is there's not a deep
philosophical discussion about whether
we should be doing this kind of research
and what kinds like what are the ethical
lines research on animals at all those
are fascinating questions instead it's a
gotcha thing did you or did you not fund
research and gain a function and did you
fund it's almost like a bio weapon did
you give
money to China to develop this bio
weapon that now attacked the rest of the
world so I mean all all those things are
pretty frustrating but is there um
I think the thing you can untangle about
Anthony fauci and gaining functional
research in the United States and equal
Health Alliance and Wuhan Institute
virology that's kind of um that's
clarifying and what were the mistakes
made sure so on gain of function there
actually has been a lot of of debate and
I mentioned before in 2011 these first
papers uh there was a big debate uh Mark
lipsich who's formerly at Harvard now
with the the US government working the
president's office
um he led a thing called the Cambridge
group uh that was highly critical of of
this work but basically saying we're
we're creating monsters they had the
funding pause in 2014 and they spent
three years putting together a framework
and then they they lifted it in 2017. so
we had a thoughtful conversation
unfortunately it didn't work and I think
that's where where we are now so I
absolutely think
um that there are real issues with the
relationship between the United States
government and Eco Health Alliance and
through that Eco Health Alliance with
the Wuhan Institute of virology and one
issue is just essential transparency
because as I see it it's most likely the
case that we transferred a lot of our
knowledge and plans and things to the
Wuhan Institute of virology and again
I'm sure that shojiang Li is not herself
a monster I'm sure of that even though
I've never met her
but there are just a different set of
pressures on people working in an
authoritarian system than people who are
working in other systems that doesn't
mean it's entirely entirely different
and so I absolutely think that we
shouldn't give one dollar
um to an organization and certainly a
virology Institute where you don't have
full access to to their records to their
databases we don't know what work is is
is happening there and I think that we
need to have
um that kind of full examination and
that's why so I understand what what Dr
fauci is doing is saying Hey What I Hear
Dr fat you think what I hear from you
Rand Paul is you're accusing me of
starting this pandemic and you're using
gain a function as a proxy for that and
we have in when there are Senate
hearings every Senator gets five minutes
and the name of the game is to translate
your five minutes into a clip that's
going to run on the news and so I get
that there is that kind of game gotcha
um but I also think that uh the Dr fauci
and uh the Nia the National Institute of
allergy and infectious diseases and the
NIH should have been more transparent um
because I I think that
in this day and age where there are a
lot of people poking around and this
whole story of coveted Origins uh we
would not be where we are if it wasn't
for a relatively small number of people
and and I'm I'm part of there are two as
I know two groups one is these internet
sleuths known as drastic and a number of
them are part of a group that I'm part
of called it's it's not our official
name but called the Paris group it's
about two dozen experts
um uh around the world but centered
around some some very high level French
academics so we've all been digging uh
and meeting with each other regularly
since uh since last year and our
governments across the board certainly
China but including the United States
haven't been as transparent as they as
they they need to be so there's
definitely mistakes were made on all
sides and that's why for me from day one
I've been calling for a comprehensive
investigation into this issue that
certainly obviously looks at China but
we have to look at ourselves we did not
get this right